tout a commencé pour elle avec un
porte-clé de Jean Lecanuet mon invité a
été président de département ministre et
aujourd'hui député une pionnière à sa
façon
[Musique]
bonjour Brigitte klinkerte bonjour Alors
vous n'êtes pas du genre à monter sur
les barricades le point levé le point
levé et pourtant vous avez été un peu à
l'origine d'une petite révolution dans
votre département le département du
Haut-Rhin s'était à l'occasion des
élections cantonales en 1994
mon ambition n'était pas du tout d'être
la première femme au Conseil Général du
Rhin mon ambition c'est plutôt de servir
Colmar et l'école Mariens ce que je
souhaite apporter de plus c'est je crois
ma sensibilité ma ma façon en tant que
femme d'aborder les problèmes
c'est-à-dire peut-être une façon plus
concrète plus réaliste alors on l'a
compris à travers cette archive vous
avez été la première femme élue au
département du Haut-Rhin je le disais il
y a un côté pionnière chez vous mais pas
forcément militante des droits des
femmes en tout cas pas à vos débuts
pourquoi alors en effet je suis devenu
avec le temps militante du droit des
femmes parce que tout simplement j'ai
été élu conseillère générale en 1994
première femme et je me suis dit voilà
j'ai ouvert la porte aux femmes dans
trois ans dans 6 ans d'autres vont
intégrer notre assemblée et il a fallu
attendre la loi sur la parité et bien
pour que d'autres femmes viennent me
rejoindre et du coup autant j'étais
contre les quota je me suis dit ben oui
il faut qu'on passe par une loi sur la
parité pour permettre aux femmes de
s'exprimer en politique c'est-à-dire
vous avez découvert que rien ne pourrait
se faire naturellement pour les femmes
dans ce milieu là c'est oui que c'était
que c'était compliqué parce qu'il faut
s'imposer que il faut aimer le pouvoir
moi j'aime le pouvoir mais pour être au
service des autres et pas le pouvoir
pour le pouvoir c'est ça quand vous
dites dans cet archive que quelque part
les femmes font de la politique
différemment des hommes c'est ce que
vous avez en tête oui je pense
qu'effectivement on est on est beaucoup
plus concrète
on est aussi je dois dire tenace en tout
cas je suis connu pour ma ténacité et
parce que moi je fais de la politique au
sens noble du terme pour aider les
autres pour aider les gens alors que les
hommes sont peut-être plus obsédés par
le pouvoir oui je pense que souvent il
faut pas généraliser mais souvent c'est
le pouvoir pour le pouvoir je vais vous
raconter une petite expérience en 2008
j'étais candidate la tête de liste aux
élections municipales à Colmar je me
souviens bien qu'à l'époque j'avais
beaucoup d'hommes qui venaient qui
voulaient intégrer ma liste non
seulement il voulait être sur ma liste
mais vous voulez être adjoint voir tout
de suite première adjointervé tout de
suite les postes de commandement alors
que les femmes je vais aller j'ai dû
aller les chercher c'était pas pareil
parce qu'elle se disait est-ce que je
suis compétente est-ce que j'aurai le
temps et je n'ai pas d'expérience en
2017 vous avez franchi une étape de plus
vous avez été élu présidente du
département est-ce que ça a été
compliqué pour certains hommes de de
vous accepter dans ces fonctions c'était
non
alors certes je pense que ce sont les
femmes aussi qui m'ont beaucoup aidé à
être élu mais je suis aussi une femme de
consensus et donc en alliant à la fois
mes compétences et le sens du consensus
ça a été assez facile mais là aussi une
petite anecdote quand on savait que
j'allais être élu présidente les
services m'ont dit ah oui on pourrait
peut-être déjà commencer à préparer le
papier à lettre et il me qu'est-ce qu'on
met sur le papier à lettre présidente
trouver la question farfelue il dit
évidemment présidente et j'avais un
collègue à mes côtés qui m'a dit mais tu
es sûr ben oui mais pourquoi ah mais
parce que Président c'est quand même
beaucoup plus fort que présidente les
mentalités
pas totalement évolué encore vous êtes
engagé en politique à l'âge de 18 ans
vous avez rejoint le CDS le centre des
démocrates sociaux sauf qu'à l'époque
votre mère a eu du mal à l'accepter
pourquoi alors maman était la fille mon
grand-père qui avait été qui était maire
de Colmar pendant 30 ans et je pense que
souvent quand même la politique saute
une génération parce que les enfants se
rendent bien compte et bien des mais que
ça demande beaucoup de temps un
investissement très très fort et quand
je lui ai dit un jour Maman là je vais
partir en mois de juillet à l'université
d'été des jeunes démocrates sociaux elle
m'a dit mais c'est juste pas possible
enfin elle n'en revenait pas votre
grand-père maternel donc marqué la vie
politique locale de Colmar en étant mère
pendant 30 ans à l'âge de 9 ans
vous-même vous étiez déjà très intéressé
par la politique au point de vouloir
l'accompagner au meeting de Jean
Lecanuet je crois que vous en avez même
gardé un souvenir en effet j'allais à
l'époque à l'école primaire et puis on
annonce la venue de Jean-Luc Lecanuet
pour mything à Colmar j'avais très très
envie d'y aller mais c'était juste pas
possible j'avais 9 ans et puis j'avais
classe et du coup mon grand-père m'a
rapporté et bien un joli porte-clés
précieusement en photo ici mais
magnifique collector
la principale personnalité de sa famille
politique centriste et candidat à
l'époque à l'élection présidentielle
cet engagement de votre grand-père donc
il a il a compté dans votre propre
engagement ça a été déterminant pour
vous ou pas forcément alors difficile à
dire c'est vrai que mon grand-père
m'emmenait par exemple les jeudis
après-midi ou les dimanches matin voir
l'un ou l'autre chantier c'est ainsi que
j'ai le souv d'un champ ou sur lequel il
y avait rien mais je voyais que il y
avait des travaux là et que pour mon
grand-père c'était très important et en
fait il s'agissait de l'implantation de
la première entreprise l'entreprise
Timken une entreprise américaine dans ce
qui allait devenir par la suite la zone
industrielle de Colmar et ça c'est pour
vous c'est ça a été ça a été ça a été
marquant pour moi et bien de créer des
emplois pour pour l'école Maria et puis
d'autres souvenirs une fois qu'ils
voyaient que je commence à m'intéresser
à la politique il m'a emmené avec lui à
des réunions franco-allemandes d'élus
franco-allemand et là aussi j'ai trouvé
que ce que mon grand-père faisait était
juste incroyable parce qu'il avait été
résistant
emprisonné par les Allemands condamnés à
mort même par par les nazis pas par les
Allemands par les nazis et il a été l'un
des premiers attendre la main à nos
voisins de l'autre côté du Rhin pour
revenir sur ces liens
qui vous tiennent à cœur avec
l'Allemagne et pas seulement aussi avec
avec la Suisse j'aimerais qu'on évoque
ce qui s'est en 2020 dans votre
département que vous présidiez à
l'époque avec le covid ça a été le
premier département touché la situation
est vite devenue catastrophique il y
avait plus aucune place dans les
hôpitaux pour prendre en charge les
patients et c'est là que vous avez pu
éprouver en quelque sorte la solidité
des liens que vous avez tissé au fil du
temps avec vos homologues allemands
un peu tout à fait je me suis retrouvé
le 20 mars 2020 dans mon bureau de
présidente du conseil départemental du
Haut-Rhin j'entendais les hélicoptères
sanitaires qui partaient avec des
malades de réanimation des avions
sanitaires qui partaient un hôpital
militaire qui n'en finissait pas de se
monter à Mulhouse et je me suis dit on
va jamais s'en sortir et les frontières
étaient fermées faut juste se le
rappeler d'ailleurs j'en ai pleuré que
des frontières soient fermées entre la
France et l'Allemagne et la Suisse
également j'ai adressé un mail au
ministre président du bas du würtembert
un mail également aux trois présidents
quand on Suisse voisin Belleville bal
campagne et du Jura et je les ai appelés
à l'aide je leur ai dit ben voilà on
n'arrive pas à s'en sortir est-ce que
vous avez la possibilité de prendre des
patients de réanimation chez vous j'y
croyais pas je me suis dit je vais pas
avoir de réponse sur une réponse
négative et les réponses sont arrivées
le soir même et le lendemain matin et
dès le lendemain des premiers patients
alsacien français ont été transférés en
Allemagne et puis ensuite en Suisse et
ensuite dans d'autres pays et ces
décisions ils les ont prises pour vous
en raison de ces liens d'amitié parce
que j'imagine que dans l'opinion
publique allemande ça devait pas être
évident de faire passer cette ça n'était
pas évident vous savez j'ai coutume de
dire que les relations transfrontalières
et la coopération internationale repose
sur deux choses il faut une volonté
politique et il faut des liens étroits
avec ses partenaires et je pense que
c'est sur la base de ces liens étroits
que j'avais réussi à construire que ces
transferts de patients ont pu se faire
et que donc la coopération
transfrontalière a sauvé des vies c'est
ce que j'allais vous poser comme
question vous pensez avoir sauver des
vies grâce à ça c'est difficile de
mettre ça en avant mais clairement
encore au mois de septembre dernier un
couple est venu à ma permanence à Colmar
et en pleurant m'a dit et bien moi je
suis là donc c'était un homme moi je
suis là en grâce à vous si vous n'aviez
pas été là je ne serai certainement plus
plus envie j'imagine c'est fierté pour
vous de Spa dire une fierté mais parce
que c'est terrible quand même à entendre
mais en même temps jamais jamais en tant
que femme politique en tant qu'élu je ne
pensais un jour où et sauver des vies
pouvoir être utile à ce point-là par un
engagement public exactement
en 2022 après votre élection à
l'Assemblée vous êtes présenté pour
devenir la présidente du bureau de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande et vous avez été élu et
vous expliquer que c'était le seul poste
qui vous intéressait dans tous vos
postes possibles quand on est député au
sein de l'institution expliquez-nous un
peu en quoi ça consiste cette assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande parce que
je suis pas sûr que tout le monde
connaisse bien alors effectivement c'est
une assemblée qui a été créée en 2019
c'est une assemblée extraordinaire c'est
la seule assemblée binationale qui
existe au monde elle est composée de 50
députés français 50 députés du Bundestag
et nous nous réunissons nous travaillons
en groupe de travail également pour
essayer d'adopter des textes communs
donc essayer de nous mettre d'accord sur
des sujets j'ai envie de dire
stratégiques comme actuellement la
souveraineté énergétique nous allons
travailler également sur les questions
de défense mais aussi des questions
j'allais dire qui concerne le quotidien
des gens alors clairement ça n'est pas
toujours facile nous ne sommes pas
toujours d'accord mais avantage de ce
type d'assemblée c'est que nous nous
disons les choses je veux dire entre
parlementaires nous avons un langage
très clair et qui nous permet d'avancer
j'ai envie de dire vers un avenir commun
et une coopération beaucoup plus
développée un mot quand même sur votre
passage au gouvernement de Jean Castex
puisque avant d'être député vous avez
été ministre délégué à l'insertion
est-ce que votre perception de
l'Assemblée en tant que ministre de
l'assemblée et des députés étaient
différentes de celle que vous avez
aujourd'hui vous avouer que la première
fois que je suis arrivée en tant que
ministre sur les bancs le banc du
gouvernement à l'Assemblée lors des Q
âgés des questions gouvernement je me
suis dit mais quel cirque ici en fait
aujourd'hui on se rend compte c'est en
effet que à l'Assemblée nationale
malheureusement on ne se respecte pas
forcément les uns les autres qui a
beaucoup d'insultes qui fusent
et je le regrette et je le regrette
profondément pour moi l'Assemblée
nationale
d'ailleurs travailler avec le
gouvernement
quel qu'il soit et de quelques parties
qu'on soit pour faire avancer les
projets pour la France et c'est pour
cela que moi je me suis investie allez
on passe au à notre quiz je vous
explique le principe je commence une
phrase et ça va être à vous de compléter
cette phrase on y va
les députés qui rêvent de devenir
ministre il faut pas en rêver ça vous
arrive un jour sans que vous ne me
demandiez rien on reconnaît les
marathoniens en politique à leur
endurance le vrai endurance physique
vous le
constateznacité la ténacité alors on
vous voit avec votre club que le Marien
où avez-vous pu trouver cette photo pour
un alsacien les français de l'Intérieur
sont vraiment
sont vraiment vous savez il y a pas plus
français qu'en alsacien donc
l'intérieur c'est la façon dont les
Alsaciens parlent du reste de la France
du reste de la France il faut juste
savoir que ça n'ait absolument pas
péjoratif mais c'est voilà c'est comme
ça qu'on parle des Français outre Vosges
bon bah écoutez parce que les Vosges
qu'on le veuille ou non sur une barrière
physique alors que le rein uni est déjà
Victor Hugo disait le Rhin unitou
merci beaucoup Brigitte linker d'être
venu dans la politique et moi grand
merci à vous
[Musique]